new evidence emerges that Christine Ford
told untruths in her various stories and
testimonies related to Brett Kavanaugh
we will administer a lie-detector test
of our own to see who's telling the
truth then the New York Times breaks the
shocking story that Brett Kavanaugh was
a cool guy in high school
Cory Booker has his amoral moment Alyssa
Milano professes love for a credibly
accused rapist
Kanye won't take off the hat and we talk
about sex baby I'm Michael no listen
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
well we got a juicy show today we got a
lot of allegations we got a lot of
lie-detector tests
breaking news about Christine Ford but
before we do that I got to keep an eye
on the time because I have got to thank
our wonderful sponsor movement movement
you know movement there that company
started by those two college dropouts it
they've now sold almost 2 million
watches in 160 plus countries they
continue to revolutionize fashion on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank
I wear this watch all the time this this
one is the Atlas I believe the Atlas
from the revolver collection it is super
cool I oh I've never gotten more
compliments on a watch than on this
watch I love them and what they do is if
you bought a watch like this in a
department store it would be 300 bucks
400 bucks maybe more actually these days
maybe more but if you get it online you
cut out the middleman
the watches start at just 95 bucks you
are not going to beat that anywhere for
this kind of quality it is superb they
figured out by selling online you cut it
out you know the retail markup goes away
you get the best possible price classic
design quality construction styled
minimalism the thing I love about these
watches is they've got a kind of
old-school charm to them but they're not
pretending to be some old watch it's got
a it's got a modern aesthetic to I get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns go-to movement comm MVM
t-dot-com / co f f/a co v fe fe cy
movement keeps on growing check out
their expanding collection movement calm
/ co f fa co v fe fe they have a new
rise collection i don't have one yet
sure would like one just giving you some
early ideas for christmas prisons
movement calm em VMT calm / co v a so
we've got new juicy details coming up on
this scintillating Supreme Court
nomination process I know you're glued
to your seats to see what shocking new
allegation next is going to come up for
a milquetoast federal judge with an
unquestioned record of integrity until
five seconds ago when it became
politically convenient for analysis we
now cut to Senate Democrats
[Music]
they're so serious aren't they those
Senate Democrats they seem or they're
such sober serious people so the the new
the change in the story right now is
that an ex-boyfriend an alleged
ex-boyfriend of Christine Ford has come
out of the woodwork they allegedly dated
for about seven years and he and this
isn't just some tabloid thing like he
talked to Michael avenatti this is per a
sworn testimony that was just released
by Chuck Grassley the boyfriends name
has been redacted thus far but Grassley
is vouching for him he is contradicting
a lot of Christine Ford's testimony he's
saying that she and he would fly around
all the time on airplanes she didn't
have a fear of flying and she never
mentioned a sexual assault to him now
this part we know is true because
initially remember Christine Ford said
oh I can't testify before the Judiciary
Committee because I'm I'm terribly
afraid of flying it's incapacitating I
just don't fly and then we found out she
did she flies to New Hampshire she flies
to Hawaii she that's a pretty long
flight she flew to French Polynesia as
she's flying all over the place so he
said okay that doesn't seem to make a
lot of sense she said well okay I got
over it but I'm afraid of confined
spaces I don't like small spaces this
guy's saying they lived in a studio
apartment of his 500 square feet or
something like that
he also says and this is crucial that he
personally saw Christine Ford coach a
friend of hers on how to beat a
polygraph test
now she was asked about this on during
her testimony and so this really raises
a lot of questions we will we'll get
into what the woman who allegedly was
helped by Ford says in a second but
let's just take a look from that
testimony when Rachel Mitchell the
prosecutor hired by the Senate Judiciary
Committee hones in on this question says
did you ever help somebody to take a
polygraph test here's what Christine
Ford says have you ever had discussions
with anyone besides your attorneys on
how to take a polygraph never and I
don't just mean countermeasures but I
mean just any sort of
tips or anything like that no I was
scared of the test itself but was
comfortable that I could tell the
information and the test would reveal
whatever it was going to reveal I didn't
expect it to be as long as it was going
to be so it was a little bit stressful
hey have you ever given tips or advice
to somebody who was looking to take a
polygraph test never now when this
question came up during the hearing I
think all of us were kind of scratching
our heads saying what is this about why
I know she took a polygraph but why are
you focusing in for three questions on
this now I think we see why and there's
some weird stuff that comes out of
Ford's testimony here she says oh I was
so scared to take the polygraph test I
was so afraid to take it but I did it
anyway but Ford's people arranged the
polygraph they paid for the polygraph
test
Ford chose to do that she volunteered to
do this so if she was so afraid of it
what nobody was making her it was just
her own people doing it and she said oh
it took so long I felt like I had told
my whole life story
it just it took so long to administer
the polygraph test polygraph test was
two questions actually the guy who did
the polygraph test who administered it
to her said oh yeah it was a friendly
polygraph test that's why you know if
this were a hostile polygraph test if we
were prosecutors there was a criminal or
investigators or something like that
then it might have been a lot longer
about two questions so okay that doesn't
seem very long to ask two simple
questions then she won't give us a lot
of details about it they asked her when
did you do the polygraph test did you do
it on the day of your grandmother's
funeral day after day before she said I
don't remember well how do you not
remember it was like a few weeks ago how
could you not remember that now - to be
fair to dr. Ford her friend who the
ex-boyfriend alleges Ford helped to pass
the polygraph test her friend denies all
of this the woman's name is Monica
McLean she said that she's never been
helped by dr. Ford but the boyfriend
does say this quote dr. Ford explained
in detail what to expect how polygraphs
worked and helped McLean become familiar
and less nervous about the exam so now
we have a he-said she-said
by the way McLean signed a statement of
support for dr. Ford
a while long before these accusations
came out but there are a lot of
inconsistencies in her testimony so I
don't really know she won't give us
details about the polygraph she won't
release the psychiatrist records which
could validate some of what she said but
apparently it contradicts a lot of her
testimony and there are a lot of other
claims too that seem to be popping up so
according to this ex-boyfriend when he
and Ford were in Hawaii they would fly
around in a propeller plane so it's not
just that she took a jetliner to Hawaii
the woman who had such a terrible fear
of flying when she couldn't go anywhere
she apparently took a little prop plane
this tiny little plane that you know if
you're afraid of confined spaces don't
get in a prop plane you can't you know
you can barely move around in those
things then another a huge one so
because I got to tell you something uh
we've seen sworn testimony we've seen
public testimony be nonsense here right
avenatti is client Julie sweat Nick is
clearly a complete Looney tune but she's
giving testimony so I don't know maybe
the boyfriend is telling the truth maybe
he isn't
I've got no less reason to believe him
than I have to believe
Christine Ford that's for sure and yet
everybody especially on the left seems
to be jumping to defend forward and
trying to brush off this ex-boyfriends
allegations but you'll remember I think
a really key part of the forward
testimony seems to be falling apart
right now not because of it what the
ex-boyfriend says but because of what
the Palo Alto government says jr. where
she said that she this whole thing came
up this whole alleged sexual assault
came up because they were remodeling
their house for it and her husband and
Ford wanted to put a second exterior
door on the house because she need an
escape plan from this childhood trauma
that she couldn't get past and it was it
was all about that so well I'll let I'll
let her put it in her own words and then
we'll see why her testimony is totally
untrue I'd never told the details to
anyone the specific details until May
2012 during a couples counseling session
the reason this came up in counseling is
that my husband and I had completed a
very extensive very long remodel of our
home
and I insisted on a second front door an
idea that he and others disagreed with
and could not understand in explaining
why I wanted a second front door I began
to describe the assault in detail so two
claims here one that the second front
door in her house was because she wanted
an escape hatch to get out of there
because stemming from the psychological
trauma of this alleged assault 36 years
earlier and two that the second door
became an issue in her marriage in 2012
and that's when they had a couples
counseling session about it and that's
when some description of some assault
came up Paul Sperry had real clear
investigations has debunked a lot of
this he showed that the permit to build
an additional door in this house was not
issued in 2012 but issued four years
earlier on February 4th 2008 four years
before the therapy session four years
before this allegedly became a problem
in their marriage and those records show
that the door was a was not because she
needed an escape hatch from this delayed
psychological trauma but because she
wanted a separate entrance to her
marriage counseling office that that's
very different than saying I need an
escape hatch if you're running a little
business out of your house to have a
separate door makes perfect sense you I
want people going into your foyer or
your living room when they come into
your office also its previously been
reported that students from local
colleges Google interns would stay in
this extra room and they would have a
spare door to go out of their own
independent door when she was renting
out the room okay now she's saying
actually I mean look we know that
Christine Ford's not great about dates
she doesn't know if it's 36 years ago 35
years ago as she doesn't know if the
session was four years ago or was six
years ago whether it was ten years ago
but that's a big discrepancy four years
is a big discrepancy and it's not just
about the time it's about the cause
she's saying it was caused by
psychological trauma made an issue about
her marriage
what the building permits showing what
the timeline shows is this was about a
separate marriage counseling office and
about renting it out to college kids and
Google interns so Christine Ford has
told many untruths here untruths about
flying on fruits about traveling untrue
it's about where she was certainly
untruths about who was at this alleged
party we know this because she's changed
her story between the Dianne Feinstein
letter and the polygraph test and when
she spoke before the Senate Judiciary
Committee and when she talked to the
therapist she's told untruths about not
only who was at the party but who was in
the room at the time and coincidentally
coincidentally all of those varying
truths always seem to trend in the
direction of being unfalsifiable and of
making Brett Cavanaugh's position
indefensible making it such that he has
no way to go back and said this didn't
happen see here's the proof it all keeps
changing so is she a liar I don't know
is she telling untruths absolutely and
day by day it seems that she's lying
that's what it looks like before by the
way we've got we've got the breaking
news by the way and the evidence that
Cavanaugh is innocent here's the best
evidence we've got yet before we do that
I have got to thank a wonderful sponsor
at Lending Club you know when not only
are we gonna make a little money honey
but you can get access to some money for
those repairs that come down last minute
sometimes you need some some quick money
to make for whatever reason to pay off
certain bills to pay off high-interest
credit cards a lot of times people will
put put debt on too high interest credit
cards don't fall for that trap it is so
much easier rather than paying 18 19
percent interest on soar more on credit
cards pay off those bills with one fixed
monthly payment since 2007 Lending Club
has helped millions of people regain
control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to the bank no high interest
credit cards go to the Lending Club com
tell them about yourself how much you
want to borrow pick the terms that are
right for you
if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited it into your
bank account in as little as a few days
that makes it pretty easy it's the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over 35 billion billion with a B in
the loans issued
don't be stupid about money don't be
penny wise and pound foolish if you
gotta spend some money now make a repair
pay off some loans do it and so that
you're not paying more money in the long
run go to Lending Club com / Knolls
Canada wles check your rate in minutes
borrow up to 40 grand
that is Lending Club com / Knolls KO
wles
Lending Club com / Knolls KO wles and
make sure you budget in an extra
dollars for that daily wire subscription
that's maybe that's the most important
use for your money in the short term all
loans made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender Lending Club com /
Knowles so the reason that I suspect
that's something even a little more than
innocent untruths is going on is because
they keep adding up regardless of
whether this boyfriend is legit between
the travel between the the planning of
building their house between the timing
of accusations because I'm just starting
to think maybe there's something a
little fishy going on here the other
reason I think this is because the left
is moving on if the left the New York
Times CNN the Democrats on the Judiciary
Committee if they really believed that
these Christiane Ford allegations were
true they'd be harping on them notice
that they're not harping on them they're
talking about some party at Yale and his
fraternity did something and he threw
ice at a bar and blah blah blah whatever
so on this point the New York Times has
a new scoop this one just came out last
night it's breaking news I don't know
are you make sure you're sitting down if
you're driving pull over to the side of
the road this one is pretty shocking it
turns out that in high school Brett
Kavanaugh was a cool guy this is the
scoop this is from the 1983 a letter
from Brett Kavanaugh the New York Times
reports quote one night during his
senior year according to classmates who
witnessed it
judge Cavanaugh triumphantly hoisted an
empty beer keg above his head in
recognition that he and his friends were
well on their way to reaching their goal
of polishing off yeah I don't even know
if I can say it 100 kegs during the
academic year an achievement they later
boasted about in their yearbook oh my
gosh he probably smoked cigarettes - he
probably smoked cigarettes do we are
there is there any breaking news on that
yet did he ever did he ever like eat too
much candy on Halloween and then feel
sick afterwards that monster bad guy I
bet EJ walk - by the way I don't want to
make I don't want to make uncorroborated
accusations but I bet one time when the
the red hand was on the sign he crossed
the street anyway you sick monster you
can't you don't have the temperament to
be on the court you had beer in high
school no but does anyone
oh no everybody has fear in high school
never mind I'm sorry I guess I got that
wrong every single person
this is the best they got they this one
makes the ice throwing at the bar in New
Haven seem like I don't know the Teapot
Dome scandal you know I mean really this
is really sad guys
wonderful news for Brett Kavanaugh again
cocaine Mitch seems to have been playing
this pretty smart I really think this
vote should happen two weeks ago but
every day that this has been going on I
really think it bodes well for Cavanaugh
Lindsey Graham yesterday suggestion if
they shoot down Cavanaugh if Jeff Flake
for instance is signaling he might not
vote for Cavanaugh because Jeff Flake is
a despicable coward they're gonna change
the word Quisling and the dictionaries
would be flaking now and coincidentally
I suppose that in a way that is sort of
what flaking means so all nature is but
art unknown today if they do that they
should rename innate him it will be a
red tsunami it will be a red wave we're
gonna pick up a lot of states it's gonna
be beautiful so either way I guess
that's a win-win the Democrats are
behaving in a really immoral way here
this is beyond just tough politics I can
forgive tough politics I get it it's not
a big deal but to ruin this guy's life
to say that we should not have any due
process in America the people should be
presumed guilty until proven innocent
that is really wicked behavior that's
really in oral and nobody is better at
inverting morality and inverting virtue
I think then Cory Booker in his weepy
weird press conferences here is Cory
Booker talking about our moral moment so
my hope is that just beyond the vicious
partisan rancor that is going on beyond
the accusations we don't lose sight of
what this moral moment is about in this
country and ultimately ask ourselves the
question is this the right person to sit
on the highest court in the land for a
life time appointment when their
credibility has been challenged by
intimates people that knew the candidate
well as a classmate when his temperament
has been revealed in an emotional moment
where'd you use language that that
frankly shocked a lot of us and then
ultimately not whether he's innocent or
guilty this is not a trial but
ultimately have enough questions be
raised that we should not move on to
another candidate it's not about whether
he's innocent or guilty you heard Cory
Booker say it it does it who cares if
he's innocent or guilty we don't like
him so we're gonna ruin his life and
call him a rapist Cory Booker by the way
who wrote an op-ed about how he groped a
girl at a party when he was a young man
how he was groping her how he actually
did what Brett Kavanaugh apparently has
been falsely accused of doing what it
seems the brick has been falsely accused
of viewing cory booker actually did and
he goes out there with his earnest face
and his warbly little earnest voice and
he says we're in a moral moment and
that's why we need to destroy the
innocent regardless of their innocence
regardless of their guilt we need to
destroy people without any evidence
because I'm Cory Booker he and by the
way I didn't notice this until now is
just looking when Cory Booker gets his
really earnest face on his eyes go a
little googley they go one goes in a
little bit in one direction one goes in
the other presumably said one I can
watch CNN and the other I can read the
New York Times at the same time and get
the ridiculous propaganda going into his
head this is despicable moral moment he
I say this all the time that the left
uses language to mean the opposite of
what it really means what he is he is
describing moral behavior as running
roughshod over people regardless of
their guilt or innocence regardless of
what they do and destroying their lives
destroying their career and by the way
most importantly undercutting our
constitutional order undercutting the
right of a president to appoint judges
elections have consequences president
from one the 2016 election I know that
Democrats still deny that that happened
but it did happen
and he has the right to pick jurists
American by the way the 2016 election
was in many ways decided on the judges
that President Trump would pick I'd
think if Antonin Scalia had not died it
was so close to the election probably a
president Trump would've had a much
harder time winning that election but he
was elected largely to appoint these
kinds of judges and Cory Booker is
saying what we need to do is destroy
innocent people destroy their lives
based on nothing and he even admits I
don't even care if they're guilty I
don't even care if they're guilty any
calls that a moral moment that is an
immoral moment I know Cory Booker went
to Yale Law School - it's amazing how
much of the circles around all those ice
throwing bars in New Haven but that that
is the moral question here that is that
he's twisting this language - twisting
what he would his immoral behavior the
immoral behavior of Kamala Harris of
Dianne Feinstein of the entire
Democratic caucus especially on the
Senate Judiciary Committee it's really
really bad he's saying if enough
questions are raised then we should be
able to ruin a man's life did Cory
Booker collaborate with the Nazis did he
I'm just asking questions did Cory
Booker help the the fall of Rome did he
hasten the fall of Rome by helping the
various Goths and visit guts knock down
the walls and come on over did that
happen is that what I don't know if
that's what happened I'm just asking
questions I'm just asking questions but
what do I know
did Cory Booker blow up the Hindenburg
hmm I'm just asking questions and a look
I don't I don't know the Cory Booker
called the cause the fall of Rome
I don't know that Cory Booker
collaborated with the Nazis and I don't
know whether or not he blew up the
Hindenburg but enough questions have
been raised that I think at this point
it is only right and fair for Cory
Booker to resign his seat in the United
States Senate we have to move on this is
a moral moment okay enough how many
questions have been raised I just raised
like three how many other but I bet you
guys are raising questions in the
comments and on Twitter right now there
are a lot of questions it's the only
right thing to do is for Cory Booker to
step down to turn himself in to the
police
to serve a life sentence for
collaborating with the Nazis questions
questions have been raised so that's
their moment and I actually like this
moral moment one cuz I get to make fun
of Cory Booker but - because injustice a
feeling of injustice is driving people
in droves toward the GOP driving them in
droves this was the thought in 2016 the
thought that Hillary Clinton could get
away with what she did you know Richard
Nixon lost the prep
resigned the presidency after he won a
landslide election he resigned the
presidency because he deleted 11 minutes
of tape Hillary Clinton used a bleached
bit to wipe entire servers destroy years
and years of federal records what did
this federal records show I guess we'll
never know because she deleted those
records and what did she face what was
her consequence for that nothing nothing
and that injustice drove a lot of people
to the polls the judicial system our
system of justice drove a lot of people
to the polls because people felt that
the Constitution wasn't being respected
that left-wing activist jurists were
running roughshod over our founding
document in the framework of our
republic drove a lot of people to the
polls I think it's doing the exact same
now I think people are watching this
Cavanaugh circus and they're saying cory
booker are you out of your mind no it
does matter if he's innocent or guilty
it does matter if people make
accusations within statutes of
limitations it does matter if there's
evidence corroboration or if people are
contradicting themselves in testimony
like christine ford justice does matter
so keep it up man you know republicans
are shooting way up in the polls in
these swing states in seats they're
seven seats that are being held by
democrats that's happening in north
dakota it's happening in Missouri it's
happening in Montana it's happening in
India it's having it all over the place
so keep going man keep talking about how
it doesn't matter guilt or innocence
this this cynical question that we find
all the way back in Scripture which is
what is truth Oh what is truth fine keep
asking it we're gonna we're gonna get
that red wave in November Alyssa Milano
is demonstrating this beautifully I love
Alyssa Milano she you know she's been
the craziest of the of the anti
Cavanaugh people she showed up to the
hearing I don't know why she should
Diane Feinstein invited her so that she
could she was sitting there at the
hearing oh [ __ ] because she thought she
was in a movie or something there's
Brett Kavanaugh up there and she's got
her glasses down holding up a believe
all women sign she's staring daggers
into the guy the trouble for Alyssa
Milano just like the trouble for
Democrats is that the Internet is
forever in history is long so I don't
know who dug it up yesterday flicka's
talks Austin Fletcher sent sent it over
to me there was a 2012 tweet that Alyssa
Milano sent down
the tweet reads quote Bill Clinton I
love you so much like crazy amounts of
love Alyssa Milano hashtag believe all
women holding up the believe all women
well she says Brett Kavanaugh is a
rapist he hasn't even actually been
accused of rape other than by a vanadis
of loony-tune client but it certainly
hasn't been accused by rape of doctor
Ford or anybody and she said I believe
all women Calvin o has got to go down I
love Bill Clinton like crazy amounts of
love now let's not forget for those of
you who need a little refresher in
history Bill Clinton has been credibly
accused of sexual assault I know we
bandy that word about a lot but if
talking if any accusations are credible
it's the ones against Bill Clinton he's
accused of rape by wanita Broderick he
was accused of assault by Kathleen
Willey Leslie Mill we and Paula Jones of
exposing himself to her this is going on
for years it happened the accusations
came out much closer to the alleged
events and they've stuck by their story
for years and years and years and in
some cases there were there was
corroborating evidence and we know that
his derelicts sexual behavior in office
came out because he was having sexual
relations with a 22 year old 21 year old
intern in the Oval Office well he was
president how do we know that because of
that little blue dress so talk about
credible accusations there Alyssa Milano
doesn't care and this is my real issue
with this because what the Cavanaugh
circus is really about as Roe vs. Wade
is whether we're going to have nine
rogue dictators on the court telling us
how we're going to live our lives or
whether we're going to leave that up to
the American people and whether certain
states can have whatever they want and
certain states can have other laws and
Roe vs. Wade took that question of
abortion out of the court of public
opinion out of the legislative process
out of the democratic process where it
belongs and we've been fighting about it
ever since
it's where the working came from its
where the torpedoing of Robert Bork's
nomination came from it's where Clarence
Thomas's attacks came from and it's
where this Cavanaugh attack is coming
from I can acknowledge the political
dimension of this Democrats want they
preen and they moralize and they get up
on their soapbox and they say we believe
all women you don't believe women
you just said your life Bill Clinton
he's been accused of sexual assault by
multiple people for years and years and
years so oh never mind never mind that's
fine look if you want to say the policy
is more important than the moral
behavior of this one guy
fair enough point if you believe that
but don't get up there and tell me that
I'm some immoral person because I think
that people should be assumed to
innocent until proven guilty or that the
questions of public policy like abortion
should be left in the legislature where
they belong or that there's no
constitutional right to an abortion or
that thirty allegations that were not
made for 36 years where there's no
corroboration whatsoever even by the
people the accuser names that maybe
they're not totally credible don't get
up there and moralize and call me a
wicked person or a misogynist or
whatever it's an outrage it just isn't
true so then the question we have to
bring ourselves to is why are we talking
about sex so much why is there so much
sex let's talk about sex baby and we
mentioned yesterday that rapist is the
new racist it's just the disgusting
epithet that they throw at people that
they don't like when you're on the left
but part of the reason that we're so
obsessed with sex first of all is a
sexual revolution ever since the 1960s
people have just talked about sex a lot
more it's been much more public people
have been much freer with sex which is
you know some people enjoy that for a
certain time Lord make me chaste but not
yet as Saint Augustine once said but it
has really permeated all aspects of the
culture why else because it's
scintillating sex has always been
scintillating there have always been sex
scandals in politics but I think most
importantly it's because the left lacks
maturity you know they wear the hats of
genitalia on their head every single
line every little joke every argument
they make is suck this and eff that do
this and screw that and you know it gets
a little their vocabulary is a little
small it's because they lack the
maturity and the intellectual resources
to discuss substantive disagreements
they do there was that study from John
Hite a few years ago that said that the
right basically understands the left the
left doesn't really understand the right
very well at all and I've always found
this to be true I was at this event with
a bunch of lefties the other night in
Hollywood
I don't think they understand our point
of view they can't articulate it they
have a very limited vocabulary and so
they only they limit their vocabulary to
like five words all of which are
scatological or gynecological or
whatever genital and you see this now
especially in their PSAs there have been
versions of this before but those kids
and by kids I mean Scooter Braun and
George Clooney and all the Hollywood
elites who actually are behind it the
ones actually behind the march for our
lives the anti-gun group they have a new
PSA out telling people why they should
vote but wait there's a little twist who
are you ready it's so clever here we go
my first time I was nervous my first
time wasn't the back of the fire I was
in a church it was amazing my first time
everybody clapped afterwards I mean I
didn't know how to do it way too pretty
you know there's so many options like
you never know what it's gonna be like
when it actually when you do it so
finally I just I just went just did it
they voted my first time with a woman
was 2016
it felt good but it ended bet you get it
it's about sex you oh you thought it was
about sex
it's about then it was about voting it
was about sex now it's about voting ha
ha ha ha so this is about the level of
political discourse on the left and also
just so sad like you know the that guys
you know my first time with a woman was
Duda you know he's wearing like the
Democrat uniform I don't know he's kind
of like doing a little pout and
everything it's really sad it's really
to borrow a phrase from our president
sad not not the manliest display here
and masculinity does really play a role
in all of this well we'll get to that
with Kanye West we'll get to that
beyond Kanye West we'll get to that with
Ambassador John Bolton is something that
a lot of people aren't talking about
when they discussed the Trump phenomenon
what's going on with Kavanagh what's
going on in our politics is manliness
masculinity a bad word for a long time
common back in style will
into all of that but first I've gotta
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube if
you're on daily wire.com thank you very
much you help keep the lights on you'll
keep coffey in my cup if you're on
facebook and youtube go to daily
wire.com you'll get me you'll get the
intro clayvin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show your test questions in the
mailbag you test questions in the
conversation none of that matters that
mm hmm that's pretty good this batch
this is an upcoming vintage this is the
vintage for after the election we're
gonna release this vintage after the
election and we're serving it up from
all of the people who were telling
everyone to go out and vote and then
they're gonna be shocked when they all
vote for Republicans when they all vote
for Donald Trump this is a kind of a
play we knew the 2016 vintage was so
popular we wanted to release it again in
2018 but Cavanagh better get confirmed
for us to be able to release it by the
way I got to tell you this Friday daily
wire will be launching the next chapter
of the podcast that I've been working on
with Andrew Clavin another Kingdom a
drew rodent I perform it this is the
first season was super popular we didn't
expect it to catch on like it did this
season if you're not caught up it's
gonna be available on the website the
first season is also going to be
available on the website subscribers to
daily wire will get early access to each
episode and all of it will be ad free
this season is super cool because we've
added this incredible visual component
to it last time I was shooting it in
Drew's attic it was all audio you heard
like ambulances in the background it
wasn't the best studio setup this time
we've got a set we've got a visual
component and it really enhances Drew's
phenomenal story it's a really really
good story and look the only times that
I ever get hired to be an actor anymore
or by Carolla and dennis prager Ted Cruz
and Andrew Clavin that's you've got to
catch it
presumably it'll be my last acting job I
ever have in my life go to daily wire
comm and subscribe
so a lot of this actually this is sort
of a tie-in with another Kingdom another
Kingdom explores themes of masculinity
and what it means masculinity and
femininity we're talking about sex baby
this whole shows about sex this whole
two weeks three weeks has been about sex
what we saw in that commercial I voted
for the first time blah blah blah is
people say I voted for a woman Oh was so
nice it's this kind of meek timid
tee-hee-hee oh I'm really gentle I'm
okay
but where's the confidence where's the
masculinity where is telling it like it
is
a lot of this Trump moment is telling it
like it is it's a lot of Kofa a it's a
lot of dragon energy who better to
expound on this than Kanye West he was
sitting down with the head of TMZ the
head of TMZ begging him begging him to
stop wearing that Magga hat that donald
trump hat Kanye West looks him right in
his face and tells it like it is there's
something you love about me yes I would
love it Kanye if you would not wear that
hat it would make me and a lot of other
people feel better in fact why don't we
say please take off the hat Kanye how's
that is that good ah then I won't do it
because you have a right to wear it but
that's amazing baby First Amendment as
an American I support our president
bottom line no matter who they are as an
American I support our president now I
already told you what this represent for
me this represents y'all can't bully me
y'all can't bully me because you can't
tell me what to do because that's what
people used to do they would snatch yo
hat off you have a starter cap and like
a big a gangbanger come up and try to
rip your hat off and ain't nobody
ripping my hat off again so that's what
it represents to me it also represents
for me masculine energy this is exactly
right again I know we're living in the
matrix
because Lindsey Graham is the backbone
of the GOP and Kanye West is the voice
of reason but he's exactly right I love
that at the beginning that TMZ guy he
says take it off please take off that
please take off the Hat Kanye West says
I'm not gonna take off that hat mm not
gonna do it
Alyssa Milano sent out this tweet
yesterday of Kanye dressed up like Trump
with the Trump hair and everything and
it said make Kanye Kanye again M kka I
think she's missing another K I think
that third K is missing somewhere from
her tweet because what she's saying is
you are Kanye West what does that mean
you're Kanye West you look a certain way
you talk a certain way you behave a
certain way you work a certain way
you're in a certain industry you can't
be a republic rat
this party owns you and you better
kowtow to the party line and he's saying
no I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna do
it he says later on in that interview he
says I support our president whoever it
is now I'm old enough to remember when
he said George W Bush doesn't care about
black people so I don't know that he
always supported the president no matter
who it is I think he especially supports
Donald Trump I think they're kindred
spirits I think they both have dragon
energy and what does that mean he spells
out what it means he said it's about
masculinity
there's a masculine energy there and
that is of course there is that's why
everything is becoming about sexier
that's why everything is becoming Donald
Trump is a an abuser he because he only
paid stormy Daniels $150,000 he should
have given her $200,000 and Cavanaugh is
a rapist even though he's never been
accused of anything like that ever in
his entire life and this guy and this
it's all about masculinity because we
are staring down the left right now and
you're saying they're just nagging us to
death they're saying well please I know
it may be he's guilty maybe he's
innocent but you just have to wait for
him and you have to and you have to and
you have to and we're looking Cory
Booker right in his quivering bizarre
googly eyed face and we're saying no you
don't get to bully us into doing this
not anymore
sorry buddy but I really want you to
take the head off not gonna tell wearing
two heads now I'm gonna wear to it I'm
gonna wear a hat on my head I'm gonna
wear I had on each fist I'm gonna wear a
hat on my kneecaps you can't bully us
anymore and that is masculine
I hardly Mansfield
this great book about manliness a number
of years ago and masculinity is not just
like knuckle-dragging
manliness is not just being some brute
to be a man is to be a gentleman to
holding the door harvey describes it
very well in this book where he says the
manliness is when you hold the door open
for a woman and you tell her to pass
through and then when there is some
robber in the room or some criminal is
walking by you look her in the face and
you say get out of my way and you go and
you fight the guy you know that those
are two sides of manliness one is
aggressive and strong one is gentlemanly
and chivalrous but there are two sides
of it and for a long time we've been
told that masculinity is toxic
masculinity is evil it's bad the future
is feminine men are scum men or trash
these are hashtags that go around
feminist twitter I'm not making this up
and what guys like all the way from
Kanye West to Donald Trump to John
Bolton to Brett Kavanaugh or saying is
no you're not gonna bully us you're not
going to push us around and quivering
lips and fake crocodile tears from the
likes of Cory Booker and Diane Feinstein
aren't gonna work anymore you're not
going to manipulate us you're not going
to twist our emotions to pervert justice
to pervert the meaning of language and
to pervert or constitutional republic
just ain't gonna happen sorry buddy and
they can't take it they haven't been
Democrats have not been talked to this
way in a very long time but it's a
beautiful thing and that's virtuous the
Democrats virtue signal but that's
virtue virtue comes from veer the Latin
word veer which is man there's a manly
component to virtue it ties in with
political correctness it ties in with
this innocent until proven guilty and
not getting torpedoed for saying
impolite words on a hidden camera for
not believing one sex over the other
believe all women don't believe any men
believe women by virtue of their being
women disbelieve men by virtue of their
being men it ties into policy to the
United Nations to Israel to North Korea
to the trade deals to the International
Criminal Court John Bolten some of this
up beautifully the other day you know he
was he was asked he referred to the so
called state of Palestine and he the
some reporter said well isn't that
offend
of language and he said that's what it
is Palestine is not a state you keep
referring to it as a state so it's a
so-called state but it's not a state
doesn't meet the criteria of a state
it hasn't been recognized as a state
ever it's not a state she said okay but
but it's offensive it's true
sometimes the truth is offensive sad
sorry sorry get used to it the
international criminal the International
Court of Justice rather at the United
Nations right now is ordering the United
States to lift its sanctions of Iran you
know like the worst people on planet
earth you're saying the United States
has to lift the sanctions on Iran and do
you know what the United States if this
were the Obama administration that's
okay we'll fly over three more airplanes
full of cash but because this is the
Trump administration because we have a
little of that masculine Kayne energy do
you know what the United States said to
the UN for those of you who are only
listening because you don't subscribe I
just made a Sicilian gesture where I put
my four fingers under my chin and
flicked it forward that's what the
United States is doing to the United
Nations right now so we don't care what
you think we don't care enforce your
absurd and despicable and in-world
rulings enforce your orders on the
United States good luck buddy part of
why the left is so angry right now
is the humor of it all because we're
mocking them we're mocking these people
who say isn't the State of Palestine you
know what to call it SoCo that's
offensive we said why is it offensive
it's true do you remember during the
2016 campaign one of the moments Trump
won me over is when he referred to
anchor babies and some reporter said
that's offensive he said what's
offensive so you should call him future
future dreaming American dreamer or
citizen and he said yeah I'm gonna stick
with anchor baby that was very funny
we're mocking these silly notions and
this is what President Trump did last
night he mocked the inconsistencies the
vague and in many ways untrue in many
instances demonstrably false accusations
being hurled at the 11th hour against
Brett Kavanaugh and it was hilarious and
the leftist furious take it away
president Covino what he's going through
36 years ago this happened I had one
beer right I had one beer well you think
it was it nope that was one
oh good how did you get home I don't
remember how'd you get there I don't
remember where is the place I don't
remember how many years ago was it I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what neighborhood was it in I don't know
where's the house at her room upstairs
downstairs where was I don't know but I
had one beer that's the only thing I
remember and a man's life is in tatters
a man's life is shattered his wife has
shattered his daughters who have
beautiful incredible young kids they
destroy people they want to destroy
people these are really evil people he's
going to holding no punches back and
he's having fun while he's doing it he's
having fun while he's doing it and
they're so furious what is he mocking
here he isn't i I just want to be very
specific on where the comedy is here
he isn't mocking Ford's appearance he
isn't mocking the way that she speaks
exactly
she isn't do it you know he got in
trouble because he mocked a reporter who
had turned out had a disability and he
kind of made him look [ __ ] even
though the reporter is not [ __ ] even
though Trump has done the same
impression for plenty of other people
that he just thinks aren't all that
bright and that he disagrees with but he
got in trouble for that that's not what
he's mocking here what he's mocking here
is the flimsiness of the accusations and
he is exactly right to do it
he I mean I've been doing it now for a
few days so I I hope he's right to do it
these are so flimsy and it's perfectly
right to mock them we should be ready to
mock them much more the left says how
dare you how did that's toxic
masculinity you can't laugh it's super
serious I don't care if he's innocent or
guilty it's super serious we're saying
no it's not come down you're being
ridiculous
shh shh stop it Cory stop
you're being ridiculous sit down sit
down right now and it's it's a wonderful
thing I'm glad that we get to finally
see that here I think we should use
humor a lot more I think a lot of people
are glad that in this culture where
you've got the left totally addicted to
outrage purple hair no screaming you
know serious
chasing Republicans to their homes
keeping their children up at night
forcing them out of restaurants behaving
like little punk thug children criminals
that we can laugh at them we're not
going to take them seriously we're not
going to take them seriously and we're
not going to take inconsistent flimsy
vague constantly changing last-minute
eleventh-hour charges to derail a
perfectly legitimate a Supreme Court
nominee of hitherto unquestioned
integrity and character we're not going
to take those seriously either if you
want to bring some serious allegations
with any corroborating evidence actually
with any any evidence that it doesn't
get counter corroborated that doesn't
get refuted immediately by the people
you name then maybe we can talk about it
but if you're gonna bring us this flimsy
nonsense get out of here what are you
talking about get it you don't get to do
that
maybe you get to do that in you know in
the old days not anymore that's a
beautiful thing I will quickly mention
because all nature is but are not
unknown today on this day in history in
1995 OJ Simpson was acquitted he was
acquitted of double murder this was
after a 252 day trial it was kind of
like the Cavanaugh hearings it was all
anybody in the country could talk about
for a long time he was acquitted of
murder of Nicole Brown Simpson his wife
and Ronald Goldman her friend so that
justice was served right Oh Jay got off
justice was served not quite there was a
civil trial and OJ was found liable in
that civil trial he had to pay out
thirty five or thirty three million
dollars why do I bring this up it's
because justice isn't always clear
justice it you know it is it was the
criminal trial was that justice I don't
know was the civil trial was that
justice I don't know about that well Tom
Robinson in To Kill a Mockingbird was
accused of raping Mayella you'll
remember do we believe all women in that
case shook you because it turns out he
didn't rape her he was a scapegoat
because he was black do we should we
believe all women in that case believe
maiella
believe mrs. you miss you'll okay I
don't think so social justice is not
justice virtue signaling is not virtue
and you got to be very precise about
what's going on because I think on the
left I heard this the other night at
this event in Hollywood they're calling
this guy a rapist no no serious person
other than that Looney tune from Havana
nobody is even coming close to accusing
him of rape but they are they're saying
it's so clear it's so clear all shallows
are clear all shallows are clear and we
should be very very specific about where
the justice is who the victim is in this
case just take a quick look this was on
our campus recently what happened to a
group of students who were campaigning
and demonstrating in support of Brett
Kavanaugh in support of due process and
against kangaroo courts
there's a kid at the very end there is
just he flicks the camera ran and he's
like smiling cuz it's so ridiculous and
so great on you kid great for getting
that on video
the this woman is filled with righteous
indignation and virtue signaling she's
saying you're disrespecting survivors by
suggesting that the accused have the
right to be presumed innocent until
proven guilty that they have the right
to due process this is how demagogues
work they take you know heresy is not
the promotion of Vice / virtue it's the
promotion of one virtue to the exclusion
of the others and that isn't virtue when
you come out you say I want to support
victims of sexual assault yeah of Korda
doesn't we all do but when you use that
as an excuse to trample the rights of
the accused to trample good men to
destroy their lives and when you do it
not because you believe women not
because Alyssa Milano believes Juanita
Broderick but because you just want to
push your own petty political agenda
that is not virtue that's the opposite
of virtue but all shallows are clear and
I hope that we can pay attention to how
justice will be meted out in this case
all right we ran late we always do I
will see you tomorrow make sure you get
your mailbag questions in on Thursday
get ready for another Kingdom on Friday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Noel's show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018